we simulated a Three-Point Contest with
the worst Shooters in NBA history we got
Giannis Isaiah Thomas Russ Corey Brewer
Josh Smith and Chuck yeah everyone just
get comfortable this might take a while
first up Sir Charles who guaranteed he'd
Finish First you already know how that
went
Corey Brewer said he wanted to make
history as the worst three-point shooter
ever bro was building houses in round
one Greek Freak and Isaiah Thomas both
had 11. but wait there's 10 seconds left
and Russ is still in the fourth rack in
the championship round we had Giannis
Isaiah Thomas and who invited John Smith
to the next round let's see how Josh
does in round two wait false alarm this
ain't as easy as the dunk contest it
came down to Giannis and Isaiah and he
just couldn't hang with the Greek Freak
who won the title Giannis tried to tell
us earlier I see you cash money